okay Muslim you used to be an atheist
yeah how did that whole like change
happen well first you first from atheism
the first thing you have to do is except
that God is real so I I got there by
seeing and being exposed to all the evil
and degeneracy in the world there's an
equal and opposite Force Newton's third
law yeah for everything such an
interesting way to become super
religious is to see a bunch of evil and
be like all right there has to be God
yeah like I I want to hear more about
how he made that lead it's definitely
very unique there's an equal and
opposite reaction the equal and opposite
reaction to pure satony and debauchery
and disgusting degeneracy has to be God
it proves that God must exist I guess I
naturally reverted to Christianity
because I was raised as a Christian when
I was a child and I was living in a
Christian country but I always had a
very healthy respect for Islam even for
many years I was talking about how much
I respect Islam and then over time you
you understand that for you to truly
worship and believe in a religion you
have to respect the religion and I had
more respect for Islam than I ever had
for Christianity and that's where you
ended up believing becoming a Muslim no
I'm certainly not an Islamic scholar by
any regard I don't want to be you know
since I've since I've reverted a lot of
people ask me very detailed questions
I'm on a journey like everybody else I'm
new to this like everybody else I'm not
here to quote the Quran I don't
understand a lot of it yet I'm just
studying it like everybody else's but I
have a very healthy respect for the
belief system and that's why I
understood it's the place for me to be
how did you learn like did someone teach
you did you have Islamic friends or you
know I'm curious yes I've always had
Islamic friends so I grew up in the
Islamic the great Republic of uh sorry
the Islamic Republic of Great Britain so
what I want to say about what he said
you know he doesn't know everything yet
I think what people do is they they look
for opportunities to like like gotcha
they look for gotcha moments and they
they they if you make any opinion on
anything they start you know asking
questions
um and you should know what we if you
have an opinion you should have
something but then they'll start like
digging into like extremely Advanced
knowledge and if you don't know what
they'll be like you see you're an idiot
you don't know what you're talking about
and people just look for ways to insult
each other and I and I when he says that
like hey go easy because I'm new and I'm
Earnest and I'm earnestly learning I
hope people are responding with kindness
to that because they generally don't
people are jerks just just feel like I
don't think I don't see any reason why
people would would go after him for that
I'll just look for reasons I see I just
see it all the time like even though
some of the mean comments we get are
like I don't know like if you don't know
everything about something you shouldn't
be able to even talk about it at all and
it's so stupid because that only comes
from people who never went deep on
anything ironically people I'm just
talking about it because I just want
people to be nice well I understand that
a lot yeah you've never heard of it no
I'm not the great Republic of the
Islamic Republic of Great britistan
British stand yeah
londonistan is its capital yeah so uh I
grew up in an Islamic country uh
effectively everybody I knew was Muslim
and uh England is an Islamic Country Now
de facto it's it's it's completely
Islamic so I grew up with what
percentage of of England is Muslim I
don't know 6.5 that's not too many
England and Wales together 6.5 but that
is a lot that is a that is a lot of
people a bunch of uh very close Muslim
friends and I've always been not and
envious but certainly I've had a large
amount of adoration for their respect
for their families respect for their
culture their Brotherhood the way they
operate I've always thought it's a
fantastic way to be yeah and it's been a
very long ongoing conversation I've been
exposed to the religion and people who
were Muslim for a very long time my
entire life now since you've been so his
whole community that he hung out in was
Muslim but it's funny that he's like
yeah England is completely Muslim now
6.5 it's kind of silly that's why we
have to look [__] up when people say
things was that not jokes is that London
what did he say in London is Stan
whatever yeah that was but he said it's
you know completely Islam now and he I
knew you could tell that he was speaking
in some hyperbole but he really meant
like it is the predominant well let's
say the 45 of Christians of the country
is Christian but only 10 of those is
actually religious and goes to church so
then that's 4.5 are technically
practicing and then you know that 6.5
Muslims those are like probably 95
actually practicing where do you get
these numbers from just because muscles
that we speak to Muslims that we speak
to are practicing and are serious
Muslims but you know the the people who
were not serious Muslims are out there
we don't know what the percentage of
them are that's just you're just like
most of them are pretty serious I don't
know you're just you're just what do I
know what do you know you're just
forming it that's just a vague
assumption
just saying
Karma Muslim have you stopped drinking
alcohol yes I might drink a little bit
now and again I don't but I don't think
I I don't think I'll ever drink again a
lot of people nowadays and this is
something that kind of saddens me but
you it's one of those things you can't
just say here's the wrong but I feel
like a lot of people nowadays are
becoming Muslim for publicity no
that's not the right reason that's also
sounds like a vague what would you say
to him accusation yeah who's doing that
for publicity I mean well if you're
using if you're using God for publicity
you're that is Haram you're not truly a
Muslim or a Christian but that's okay
let him do what people do whatever they
want I wonder if and Andrew he's got to
rip a couple beers when he's out of
prison thank you guys so much for
watching make sure to like subscribe
follow me on Instagram at Sunny fast
post a bunch of cool [__] there and I'll
see you later
[Music]